in this video I'm going to define
whether it's probably the most common
type of machine learning problem which
is supervised learning I'll define
supervised learning more formally later
but it's probably best to explain I'll
start with an example of what it is and
we'll do the formal definition later
let's say you want to predict housing
prices a while back a student collected
data sets from the city of Portland
Oregon and let's say you plot the data
set and it looks like this here on the
horizontal axis the size of different
houses and square feet and on the
vertical axis the practice of different
houses in thousands of dollars so given
this data let's say you have a friend
who owns a house that is saying 750
square feet and they're hoping to sell
the house and they want to know how much
they can get for the house so how can
the learning algorithm help you one
thing a learning algorithm might be able
to do is put a straight line through the
date arrow so the fit a straight line to
the data and based on that it looks like
maybe their holes can be so full maybe
about 150 thousand dollars but maybe
this isn't the only learning algorithm
you can use and it might be a better one
for example instead of fitting a
straight line to the data we might
decide that it's better to fill a
quadratic function or a second-order
polynomial
to this data and if you do that to make
a prediction here then it looks like
well maybe they can sell the house well
closer to $200,000 one of the things
we'll talk about later is how to choose
and how to decide do you want to fit a
straight line to the data or do you want
to fit a quadratic function the data and
there's no fair picking whichever one
gives your friend the better house to
sell but each of these would be a fine
example of a learning algorithm so this
is an example of a supervised learning
algorithm and the term supervised
learning refers to the fact that we gave
the algorithm a data set in which the
right answers were given that is we gave
it a data set of houses in which for
every exam
all in this data set we told it what is
the right price what was the actual
price that that holds so for and the TAS
of the algorithm was to just produce
more of these right answers such as for
this new house you know that your friend
may be trying to sell to define a bit
more terminology this is also called a
regression problem and by regression
problem I mean we're trying to predict a
continuous value output namely the price
so technically against prices can be
rounded off to the nearest cent
so maybe prices are actually discrete
value but usually we think of the price
of a house as a roll number was a scalar
value as a continuous value number and
the term regression refers to the fact
that we're trying to predict this sort
of a continuous value to attribute
here's another supervised learning
examples some friends and I were
actually working on this earlier let's
say you want to look at medical records
and try to predictive a breast cancer as
malignant or benign if someone discovers
a breast tumor a lump in their breast a
malignant tumor is a tumor that is
harmful and dangerous and a benign tumor
is a tumor this is harmless so obviously
people care a lot about this
let's see collect the data set and
suppose you're in your data set you have
on your horizontal axis the size of the
tumor and on the vertical axis I'm going
to plot 1 or 0 yes or no whether or not
these are examples of tumors we've seen
before are malignant which is 1 or 0 of
not malignant or benign so let's say
your data set looks like this where we
saw a tumor of this size that turned out
to be benign one of this size one of
this size and so on and sadly we also
saw a few malignant tumors so one of
that size one of that size one of that
size so on so in this example I have 5
examples of benign tumors shown down
here and 5 examples of malignant tumors
shown with a vertical axis value of 1
and let's name a friend who tragically
has a breast tumor and let's say her
breast tumor size
maybe somewhere around this value the
machine learning question is can you
estimate what is the probability what's
the chance that the tumor is malignant
versus benign to introduce a bit more
terminology this is an example of a
classification problem
the term classification refers to the
fact that here we're trying to predict a
discrete value output zero or one
malignant or benign and it turns out
that in classification problem sometimes
you can have more than two values for
the two possible values for the output
as a complete example maybe there are
three types of breast cancers and so you
may try to predict the discrete value
output 0 1 2 or 3
where 0 may mean benign benign tumor so
no cancer and one may mean a type 1
cancer I give three types of cancer
whatever type one means and two may mean
the second type of cancer and 3 may mean
a third type of cancer but this would
also be a classification problem because
this other discrete value set of outputs
corresponding to no cancer or cancer
type 1 or cancer type 2 or type 3 in
classification problems there is another
way to plot this data let me show you
what I mean I'm going to use a slightly
different set of symbols to plot this
data so if tumor science is going to be
the attribute that I'm going to use to
predict malignancy or benign Ness I can
also draw my data like this I'm going to
use different symbols to denote my
benign and malignant or my a negative
and positive examples so instead of
drawing crosses I'm now going to draw
holes for the benign tumors like so and
I'm going to keep using X's to denote my
malignant tumors ok I hope this make it
make sense all I did was I took you know
these my data set on top and I just
mapped it down to this real line like so
and started to use different symbol
circles and crosses to denote malignant
versus benign examples
now in this example we use only one
feature or one attribute namely the
tumor size in order to predict whether
tumor is malignant or benign in other
machine learning problems we may have
more than one feature or more than one
attribute here's an example let's say
that instead of just knowing the tumor
size we know about the age of the
patient and the tumor size in that case
maybe your data set would look like this
where I may have a set of patients with
those ages in that tumor size and look
like this and different set of patients
that look a little different whose
tumors turn out to be malignant as
denoted by the crosses so let's say you
have a friend who tragically has a tumor
and maybe their tumor size and age falls
around there so given the data set like
this what the learning algorithm may do
is for the straight line to the data to
try to separate out the malignant tumors
from the benign ones and so the learning
algorithm may decide to for the straight
line like that to separate out the two
classes of tumors and you know with this
hopefully we can decide that your
friend's tumor is more likely so if it
was over there then hopefully in the
learning algorithm will say that your
friend's tumor falls on this benign side
and is therefore more likely to be
benign than malignant in this example we
had two features namely the age of the
patient and the size of the tumor in
other machine learning problems we will
often have more features and my friends
that work on this problem they actually
use other features like these which is
clump thickness clump thickness of the
breast tumor uniformity of cell size of
the tumor uniformity of cell shape of
the tumor and so on and other features
as well and it turns out one of the
interests most interesting learning
algorithms that we'll see in this false
as a learning algorithm they can deal
with not just two or three or five
features but an infinite
features on this slide I've listed a
total of five different features right -
on the axes and three more up here but
it turns out that for some learning
problems what you really want is not to
use like three or five features but
instead you want to use an infinite
number of features an infinite number of
attributes so that your learning
algorithm has lots of attributes or
features or cues with which to make
those predictions so how do you deal
with an infinite number of features and
so how do you even store an infinite
number of things on a computer and your
computer can run on the memory well it
turns out that when we talk about an
algorithm called the support vector
machine there will be a neat
mathematical trick that will allow a
computer to deal with an infinite number
of features imagine that I didn't just
write down you know two features here
and three features on the right but
imagine that I wrote down an infinitely
long list I just kept writing more and
more and more feature that's like an
infinitely long list of features turns
out we'll be able to come up with an
algorithm that can deal with that so
just to recap in this class we'll talk
about supervised learning and the idea
is that in supervised learning in every
example in our dataset we are told what
is the correct answer that we would have
quite like the algorithms are predicted
on that example such as the price of the
house or whether a tumor is malignant or
benign we also talked about the
regression problem and by regression
that means that our goal is to predict a
continuous valued output and we talked
about the classification problem where
the goal is to predict a discrete value
output just a quick wrap-up question
suppose you're running a company and you
want to develop learning algorithms to
address each of two problems in the
first problem you have a large inventory
of identical items so imagine that you
have thousands of copies of some
identical item to sell and you want to
predict how many of these items you sell
over the next three months in the second
problem problem to you you light you you
have lots of users and you want to write
software to examine each individual of
your customers accounts so each one of
your customers account
and for each account decide whether or
not the account has been hacked or
compromised so for each of these
problems should they be treated as a
classification problem or as a
regression problem when the video pauses
please use your mouse to select
whichever of these four options on the
left you think is the correct answer so
hopefully you got that this is the
answer for problem 1 I would treat this
as a regression problem because if I
have you know thousands of items well I
would probably just treat this as a real
value as a continuous value and treat
therefore the number of items I sell as
a continuous value and for the second
problem I would treat that as a
classification problem because I might
say set the value I want to predict to
be 0 to denote the account has not been
hacked and set the value 1 to denote an
account that has been hacked into so
just like your breast cancers right 0 or
benign 1 is malignant so I might set
this be 0 or 1 depending whether it's
been hacked and have an algorithm try to
predict each one of these two discrete
values and because that's a small number
of discrete values I would therefore
treat it as a classification problem so
that's it for supervised learning and in
the next video I will talk about
unsupervised learning which is the other
major category of learning algorithm